Jennifer Lopez and Beau Casper Smart  reportedly split JLo maybe a single lady  I know for sure that you have to love  yourself first the 47 year old singer  has apparently called it quits with her  longtime boyfriend Casper the pair  reportedly broke up a few weeks ago and  separated on mutual terms the two exes  also reportedly remained amicable after  ending their relationship we're great  friends you know I love her and the kids  and they're they're incredible  Ginny and her ex appeared to have no bad  blood Casper celebrated her birthday in  Sin City last month and shared a sweet  tribute on her special day calling her  quote the light of my life earlier this  week  Casper Instagram to post that read going  back to a time before social media gonna  focus on personal connections over a  type and text existence  JLo's rep had no comment